you would come up with like random
theories you're like I figured out the
plan what you need to do is also be
sleepy then you know what she's thinking
whatever plan you have in your mind the
thing that you've spent a lot of time on
take that ball it up and throw it in the
trash my kids are very different and
have very different needs at that time
sleep is a really big struggle for our
son it's definitely an art like that
time is an art form because they're just
so quick and so all over the place
another must be like weird I put my baby
to sleep at 7:00 and she sleeps till
7:00 in the morning I'm like this guy
was up hanging out there was no going to
sleep oh I'm gonna be reading and
cuddling and then you kiss them like
they do in the movies and you turn the
light off and they all go to sleep and
when it doesn't work that way it's tears
it's crying they're so lovable and
annoying at the same time and you would
always come up with
you can't look her right in the eye
patting them continuously on the butt
but like that works without fail so I
close my eyes to try to get him calm him
down and be like look at daddy and mimic
what daddy's doing sleep she likes music
a lot hey brushing time it's TV 13 time
mommy loves you
oh so much Ellie gets the coconut
popsicle she'd be so happy she'd take
her nuke out and she'd say uh most
important ingredient to a successful
bedtime is staying on schedule I would
say the most important thing about
entire routine is remaining very
flexible when we brought Morocco home
that first night all the way from
Ethiopia to Virginia the first thing we
did was give her son his first bath at
home house my first real moment as mom
you can't put her in it she'll be mad if
you bet
got a splash on going to be in she just
likes being in the water she's just kind
of laying back like this I think it
makes them feel very fancy and luxurious
it's their own personal mommy spot every
night I took her to a babe massage class
is like a way to bond with her I think
it also helped her fart yeah relaxing
and farting are like this I think we use
the pink good smelling lotion and we all
just rub them down and I'd always tickle
his feet
you still will ask me sometimes like how
you put lotion on my feet now his feet
stink so I say if we don't put lotion on
our babies they will look halfway like
the dusty ghosts my youngest is obsessed
with cuddling but he can't say it so we
call them Tuttle's and what he considers
cuddling is like planking on top of me
I've one on my chest and the other gets
the legs they have to kind of switch off
and compromise who gets the majority of
my body it's like way off
you sound like though we're his family
sprinkle the sleepy does down her legs
and then sit all your legs are so tired
they're so tired then your head and your
head is all your mind is so tired and
it's time for you to sleep when she was
really young it would work really well
is what it's like a magic trick and then
she just be there is just nothing better
than when you tuck them in and then you
walk back past their door and they're
sleeping I would do whatever you wanted
to get you to sleep so peacefully like
this I love you so much it makes me feel
like something is being done right
because they feel safe caring for them
and loving them gives me a lot of
purpose I am a more loving and caring
person because of their yeah
give them a kiss thank you
[Music]